ragazzi è il momento di decollare tutti
quanti so che mi piacevano piloto io
oggi mi vesto anche a puntino perché
come capitano è giusto che io lo faccia
presente mio zaino perché per andare in
cabina di pilotaggio e giusto che
colmino metta le cose che servono per
pilotare un aereo e quali sono queste
cose visto che sapete come guido bene
gli aerei guido e non piloti guidi un
video generare la patente
mettiamo all'interno di questo dai vita
tramite reversibile potete anche
riversarlo cosa che io faccio per essere
molto più piccole come capitano già alti
le si vede cosa prendiamo per pilotare
mostra erano innanzitutto cose utili beh
certo innanzi tutto questo qua serve
perché zio quando tour è poi così
volandri non si stacca se non da quelli
nei ritiri il volante e metti questo in
riserva a fantastiche ai ragazzi se ci
viene poi dici ma come mai
come fanno a fare ste tratte lunghe
episodio che mi viene fame viene pagata
all'interno delle nazionali in una
pentola
speriamo è una padella quella e per
concludere la faccenda giustamente se
dobbiamo capire quanto tempo ci mette ad
alternare come fanno regolarsi piloti
perfetto al bacio a quello metterlo
nella tasca piccola che cosa io piccola
sarli spazio ora è il mattatore sparsi
un pò come partito c'è anche la scritta
rifrangente a voi non ci sia spazio
quella è la prima cosa a questo punto
chiediamo lo sanno
ringrazio anche seven programmi dato
ormai notissimo andiamo a pilotare il re
ei ricordati chi sei
certo non sa bene c'erano anche queste
perché loro sanno saranno quest'anno gli
occhi ci siamo incamminati dio lager
dove sta andando
la camminata dato che sono a napoli
esattamente a napoli voglio provare a
fissarli dentro speriamo che non ci sia
nessuno voglia fare sta cosa io lo
faccio nel gioco perché comunque se non
lo faccio nel gioco io non la fa nessuno
qui proviamo a ficcarci dentro il
presule vediamo che succede dal
capodichino e la partenza vediamo se
riesco a raggiungerlo in modo sporco
demonio che partenza ora di vino fatto
perché lo sta guardando aereo tavor andò
in flux sono in piena manetta ecco
napoli napoli meravigliosa allora il
vesuvio a quanto pare alle mie spalle
proviamo a fare una virata di centro che
è bella cosa na jurnata famme capì fame
capi se simile voglio ditemelo voi nei
commenti
voi lo sapete meglio di me allora mi
ficcare direttamente qua dentro però non
posso fa andiamo al vesuvio è un pelo
lontano costernato volo renderizzato un
poco si sa e lottare del premio concreto
sia il mio computer
la faccenda è che il mio computer regge
fino a un certo punto sei il mio
computer è veramente potente ripetono la
duecentesima volta non lo sto facendo
andare al massimo perché il mio computer
al massimo questo gioco non lo regge o
che non lo regge neanche vostro non
regge niente
manco il computer della nasa lo regge
bene il suo gioco al massimo quindi non
scassa dura come si dice qua quindi va
bene comunque la rappresentazione è
abbastanza buona nonostante il mio
computer di niente male il vesuvio lo
vedo vediamo di rendere giustizia a ca
di giulio ficchiamo c dentro c'è un
aereo che sta sorvolando che qua sta
sorvolando molto perché comunque stesso
bianco online e ragazzi gay che vediamo
in giro
perché potrebbe capitare leader on air
in giro gente online che sta giocando
questo gioco è anche online sta cosa mi
sento di dirla c'è qualcuno l'aeroporto
non so chi ma chissenefrega tanto dalla
distanza non lo vedo però non gli venga
la società mi sa che voglia scattate
prima io dentro desidera vediamo allora
ragazzi le mie ultime parole sono lascio
il canada pietro vediamo che lo tratti
bene mi raccomando in for guys pietro
rendimi giustizia perché io vincevo
sempre quindi non fare cazzate grazie
comunque ragazzi e meravigliosa anche
sociali simulator napoli cosa posso
dirlo tante il fatto che l'unica cosa
che non è rappresentativa e il cibo
perché sull'aereo non mi fanno magna
però guarda c'è anche uno stadio del
napoli e questo aspetto che dello zoom
ecco qua perché arrivati a un certo
punto diminuiscono la velocità famo
prima così ci casco direttamente nemmeno
c'è qualcosa di vivo poi c'è qualcosa su
un chiosco bar ma non c'è una casetta
c'è una casetta sul lo sapevo ma che
diminuiamo e rendiamo omaggio a questo
video cercando di schiantarmi con
orgoglio testa atterrarci dentro a posto
ciao mamma è stato bello
oddio oddio charice bene è stato
divertente
va bene ragazzi abbiamo direttamente su
roma perché effettivamente sava fatto
napoli facciamo roma fine fanno un po
tutto oggi fanno oggi guida turistica
sfido mette a pagamento su youtube
premium
andiamo direttamente a roma anche se
effettivamente io da fiumicino non ci
sono arrivata proprio se tu mille zoom
massima ok che già è meglio
signori a decollo ormai ragazzi decollo
siamo abbastanza esperti nessun problema
comunque raga io ti faccio le parole che
secondo me merita cioè se tu guardi
all'interno dell'aereo
siamo in due i cartocci 2 e tratos e tu
entri e poi ti giri in cella che
permettendo non c'è nessuno sa cosa non
l'ha ancora capitano ragazzi beccare
cose non è male se non me lo punta lui
che mi dice guarda qua io mi sa che non
lo becco è però vabbè vediamo
raga sono veramente ignorante su roman
sono veramente ignorante questo credo
che sia
insomma a casa del gesù cristo poi
magari mi sbaglio ecco qua allora vedo
già un po tutto devo solo peccare i
ragazzi non solo scusatemi ma ci sono
state mai dall'alto a roma quindi eccolo
qua a prosperi che vede vi sono anche un
pò ceco effettivamente non urbi et orbi
che più o meno
allora se diminuisce la velocità ma
provocati proprio a proporre dei
perfetto riusciamo a goderci inuvik di
come si vive del colosseo
vedi quanto kaki e fatta bene sta roba
vediamo se c'è giulio cesare che sta
facendo combattere qualcuno magari ci
sblocchiamo anche un po di partitella
penso di no però va beh oddio ci sono
stato qui mi chiama e bellissimo sono
stato praticamente in sei a roma
ragazzino girata parecchio però per
lavoro o dio che capì successo qua ci
sono un po i rilievi che il mio computer
fatica renderizzare non è il gioco è il
mio computer don't worry oppure qualcuno
non sono scoraggiato un po forte non ho
idea ragazzi credo sia la prima
salutiamo il club sa già che ci siamo
però vediamo di non schiantarci la
perfetta
un saluto è stato bello passare anche di
qua dovrei andare teoricamente verso
firenze perché adesso vorrei provare
firenze come diavolo no no no no è
arrivato il momento di firenze ragazzine
scopo allora rialzi per concludere in
bellezza volevo fare firenze ma una
forza astrale mi ha tirato via da qui
l'idea mi ha messo in testa una roba che
non possono fare nel primo episodio ho
volato vicino a casa mia che mi stanno
schiantato malamente anche perché volevo
con un jet non sapevo fare in gara
adesso che so pilotare un pelo meglio
voglio provare ad atterrare ragazzi puoi
provare ad atterrare a casa mia con
l'aereo sarebbe un problema non
riconoscere casa mia adesso perché con
questa era risuonata la abbastanza lento
da poter capire le cose
quindi mi faccio un rapido giro di
torino ma proprio c'è arrivo rientro
subito indietro e vado direttamente
segue perché non la soglia dall'alto
casa mia dove cacchio è chi lo seguì la
strada che facevo quando tornava da
scuola vi farà ridere sta cosa ma è vero
che sono uscite ucciso arrivare ragazzi
quindi va beh questa ragazzi quella che
vedete in lontananza e torino adesso 30
non parlar larga così in modo tale da
rientrare e proprio beccare casa mia
precisamente magari non entrarci dentro
l'aereo però perché ci tengo comunque a
finire il video che magari topino tanto
sul serio che quindi non entro in casa
mia o chiave per chi mastica torino
corso giulio cesare sto cercando corso
giulio cesare sempre una che non capisco
una sega dall'alto quindi figuriamoci il
polso giulio cesare a posto quindi
esattamente come avevo fatto nel primo
episodio molto bene piano perché qua al
casinò ok scuola mia era tipo qua più o
meno
vorrei di se ne frega nuovo piano allora
prendiamo la strada a sinistra ok piante
o andare veramente piano da questa
strada non la conosco così veloce cioè
il proprio strano dal cavalcavia
ok perfetto andiamo un pelo avanti ok so
dove siamo dove siamo poi c'è l'altra
rotonda ragazzi ci siamo è ho peccato
sta andando a casa mia tantissimo
perfetto beh mappano ma parlo di caselle
eccola equa ma fase è molto vicino a
dove sono partito male roma volevo farmi
un bel giro in modo tale da essere da
avere tutto in modo panoramico
bello come l'ho fatto a roma lo faccio
qua e ragazzi devo riuscire a tenere una
velocità tale da non schiantarmi per
terra mannaggia il cardio che è perfetto
mai abbastanza veloce da non schiantarti
sì allora questa quella entrata perfetto
ma palo di caselle allora casa mia non
era questa qua siamo entrati nel mio
paesino ok sono entrati nel mio paesino
è con questo sic bit.ly sottofondo io vi
ringrazio per aver visto il video
ragazzi grazie mille come al solito vi
chiedo se potete lasciare un mi piace al
vino si è piaciuto mi supporta tanto
quindi unico gesto di bisogni cambia la
vita
pero nascente lo stesso ragazzi un
commento dove vorreste che io andassi
nel prossimo episodio di flight
simulator fatemelo sapere adesso nel
mentre che io cerco di atterrare il non
beccare con la r quel quell'albero nel
mezzo del addio non c'erano già non
c'era la collisione degli alberi che col
mamma sono atterrato hai visto che sono
riuscito adesso vado a parcheggiare e ci
facciamo una bella pagina spaghettata di
quelli che va la mia mamma che sono
molto buoni io nel frattempo vi
ringrazio veramente aver visto i ragazzi
commentateli ci sono tantissimi posti
dove io posso andare sono a casa va ma
scendi la scendi il cane eccolo bene per
avere tutto fantastico non è così casa
mia per niente però dall'alto lo è dal
basso procamera minatori camente
dovrebbe essere questa questa qua dove
ci stanno i le tende di dubbia
qualità insomma belle ragazze
[Musica]